it's been a long wait but Bioware has
finally pulled back the curtain on Mass
Effect Andromeda there is still plenty
of unanswered questions but here's
everything we know about the
science-fiction RPG so far
Andromeda takes place 600 years after
the events of the original trilogy the
Andromeda initiative a privately funded
mission to colonize the Andromeda galaxy
launched in 20 185 for those of you that
know your mass effect Laura this is
around the same time as the events of
mass effect 2 for arcs harboring
different species from the Milky Way
galaxy will embark on a 600 year journey
to Andromeda as well as these four arcs
there's another massive ship called the
Nexus version garson the founder of the
initiative will reside my name is Jan
Garson the founder of this unprecedented
mission each arc is led by a pathfinder
someone who is experienced in combat
science and exploration the human arc
and the one you'll be assigned you is
called Hyperion now just like the
original trilogy you will be able to
play as either a male or female
character your character will go by the
name writer and you will become the
Pathfinder unlike the original trilogy
both male and female writer will play a
role in Andromeda whichever one you
don't pick will take up a supporting
role in the plot there we are all these
points could be vaults on other worlds
writers father will also play somewhat
of a role in Mass Effect Andromeda he is
the original Pathfinder this guy who has
appeared prominently in Mass Effect
Andromeda marketing looks to be writers
father he's also voiced by Clancy Brown
aka mr. Krabs okay money I mean no
children it's time for the grand
unveiling of money honey but what about
the aliens so far we've seen Solarians
asari and crogans but Bioware has also
confirmed that there will be turians
whether or not we will see the Vorta elk
or batarians or some of the other
species is still up in the air the
trailer also showed off a new species
called the cat and if you're curious
what her name is it's PB
on top of that bioware also confirmed
that loyalty missions from mass effect 2
will return and you will be able to get
it on with your crew members
as well as becoming the new Pathfinder
it sounds like you will also have access
to plenty of new weapons vehicles and
tools the new mako like all-terrain
vehicle is called the nomads and it will
be key when it comes to exploring
planets the normandy replacement is
called The Tempest it looks bigger than
the Normandy but we don't really know
much about it hopefully we will be able
to pilot this thing the leaks and rumors
say yes but we'll just have to wait for
an official word from bioware on that
one the Andromeda initiated video also
showed off some new and returning
weapons the carnufex is back as well as
the tempest from two and three it sounds
like you will also have the ability to
establish colonies on planets you
explore we don't know the specifics on
this one but I have a feeling it could
play a big role in Andromeda and finally
we haven't seen much of the gameplay but
according to Mac Walters creative
director Andromeda will attempt to
strike a balance between action and
role-playing there will be destructible
environments to 24 player multiplayer
and new biotics and other skills even
with all this new info there is still
plenty we don't know about Andromeda and
that just might be the most exciting
thing about it Andromeda is scheduled
for a spring 2017 release date but in
the meantime stay tuned to gamespot all
the time has come to prepare ourselves
for a future beyond the Milky Way a
future that begins 600 years from where
we stand in a time place among unknown
stars and unseen dangers
and so we issue this calls to the brave
the inquisitive to the Trailblazers of
the human race as an invitation to stand
on the shoulders of those who came
before and challenge yourself to go
further begin your journey